Two decades have passed, but like so many people,
I can still clearly remember where I was when 9/11
happened. I was on shift, running a planning
shift for DW when four civilian air planes
were hijacked and turned into weapons. These
pictures, the collapsing Twin Towers, the fear,
the screams, the people, the dust - all of
that unfolding in real time on television.
Very soon attention turned to one country,
Afghanistan. Why? Because of al Qaeda.
The terrorist network had established
its main base in Afghanistan and was
identified as the perpetrator of 9/11.
So to hunt down al-Qaida, the United States
and its allies invaded
Afghanistan,
which back then was ruled by the Taliban regime.
Now, 20 years later, the international forces have
withdrawn - defeated. And the Taliban are back
in power. And this, of course, poses one burning
question: Will Afghanistan once again become a
safe haven for terrorist groups like al-Qaida?
We've been trying to drain al-Qaida
support for the past 20 years.
But every time we use a drone that
kills civilians, we're contributing to
sympathy and support for al-Qaida.
Al-Qaida definitely never disappeared
from the global picture. I'm very convinced
that once they have established a stronghold
in Afghanistan with the support of Taliban, they
will again try to reach out on the global scale.
I'm DW’s Sandra Petersmann and I’ve been
reporting on Afghanistan for the past two decades.
Afghanistan in 2001 had already suffered two
decades of consecutive war. First, there was
the Soviet occupation of the 1980s. Then there
was the Civil War, very bloody, of the 1990s.
And it was precisely this civil war that brought
the Taliban to power and also led to al-Qaida
establishing its main base in Afghanistan.
Al-Qaida always had the goal to aim
geopolitically, so they wanted to establish
a worldwide caliphate. Whereas the Taliban
was a regionally focused group and
concentrated on Afghanistan especially.
Both of the organizations being jihadist
groups, but with a different focus,
they very early agreed that they could reach
their aims more successfully when they cooperated.
I think it was a marriage of convenience. Al-Qaida
was looking for a safe haven or sanctuary.
The Taliban were looking for military assistance
and support. And al-Qaida had that in droves.
It had the expertise. It had battle hardened
fighters. It had bomb makers and commanders.
From all that we know, al-Qaida had attacked
Western entities from Afghanistan before. In 1998
two US embassies in Africa were attacked, the one
in Kenya and the one in Tanzania. And we did see
retaliatory strikes after that from the US hitting
targets in Afghanistan. But then of course,
9/11 was an entirely different level.
9/11 put al-Qaida on a different scale.
In fact, it catapulted them into a different
stratosphere in how we assess terrorist
groups. This was a highly complex, well planned,
spectacular terrorist attack that shook the United
States to its core. And in my mind, fundamentally
change the way we look at global security.
The US government demanded that the Taliban
hand over al-Qaida's leadership and the Taliban
refused. And then on October 7, 2001, barely a
month after the 9/11 attacks, the first US bombs
dropped on Afghanistan and foot soldiers followed.
What happened with the beginning of the US
invasion in Afghanistan was a very quick
regime change. The Taliban regime was toppled,
but went into hiding, and with it into
hiding went al-Qaida's leadership.
Bin Laden fled. Many of his top lieutenants fled,
went into Pakistan where they received sanctuary.
And throughout 2001, until bin
Laden's death ten years later in 2011,
al-Qaida continued to launch attacks. You had
involvement in the Madrid train attacks in 2004,
the following year, the 7/7 bombings in London.
In the past 20 years al-Qaida hasn't stopped with
terrorist attacks. They were just on a smaller
scale and not emanating from Afghanistan. They
emanated from different countries as al-Qaida
has diversified, metastasized and become even
more a network of independent elements.
It was able to decentralize. And it was
able to develop affiliates and branches worldwide
from the Levant to affiliates all over the world
frankly. From North Africa down to Southeast.
Al Qaeda's training camps in Afghanistan
were destroyed, but that does not mean that
there wasn't any more terror. E specially in
Afghanistan we saw a lot of suicide attacks
against international coalition forces
and against the civilian population, which has
been and continues to be a major victim of terror.
The situation now, 20 years later, is the
Taliban are back in power more forcefully
than ever before, they really control the
entire country now. And from all that we know,
al-Qaida's core leadership is still in Afghanistan
and Taliban and al-Qaida haven't severed ties yet.
The relations with the Taliban is very much
back to the roots of 2001. They pledged a
sort of allegiance to the Taliban. They are
fiercely loyal to the Taliban, and we can expect
the Taliban answering the same way. Taliban
always refused to distance themselves from
al-Qaida. And I'm pretty sure now that they
established control over Afghanistan, they will,
to a certain degree talk about not supporting
al-Qaida, but they will do so on a factual level.
I think it behooves the Taliban to prevent
al-Qaida from using Afghanistan as a hub or
a staging ground for transnational terrorist
attacks. The Taliban's waiting 20 years to
reclaim power. They’ve finally done it. If
al-Qaida launches attacks from Afghan soil,
the West is going to do something about it.
You know, something that could end up in the
Taliban once again being usurped. And so I think
the Taliban wants to avoid that at all costs.
The question in my mind becomes if al-Qaida is
determined to regenerate and attack the West. Can
the Taliban control them?
Sandra
And let's not forget, al-Qaida is not the only
terror outfit present in Afghanistan. There is
also ISIS, the so-called Islamic State.
And if you think of that massive suicide
attack at Kabul Airport during the evacuation
campaign, that was claimed by the Islamic State.
At least on a moral level, the perceived Taliban
victory in Afghanistan has a very strong impact on
jihadist movements worldwide. At least from their
point of view, what they see is that a much less
sophisticated group of convinced believers, to use
their words, they succeeded in repelling the most
advanced military in the world, the United States.
And this is happening at the same time, the West
is pivoting from counterterrorism to great
power competition. And so between that pivot
to look at the rise of China, a resurgent
Russia dealing with the COVID 19 pandemic.
There's just going to be fewer resources dedicated
to counterterrorism right at the time that many
groups are preparing to surge.
Colin
There are estimates right now that the global
jihad jihadist movement writ large is about
over two hundred thousand fighters,
which would make it approximately
four times the size as it was on 9/11.
The United States and its coalition partners,
its allies, have done a really good job
at eliminating individual jihadi leaders.
But these decapitation strikes have
amounted to tactics without a strategy.
I do think depending what happens in Afghanistan,
what happens in Syria and what happens elsewhere
we could see future attacks that look like what we
saw in Paris in November 2015 at the Bataclan. Or
Brussels in March 2016, or you know, vehicle
attacks like we've seen in Nice and Berlin.
The central question is which area of
operations they (AQ) are focusing in.
I think for the next time in the foreseeable
future, they will focus on the Asian area because
they have to reestablish their global outreach,
but they will not stop to plan international
attacks against Western targets as well.
We've been trying to drain al-Qaida support
for the past 20 years. But every time
we use a drone that kills civilians,
we're contributing to sympathy and support for
al-Qaida. Now, if you look at the situation in
Afghanistan at the moment, the US is bereft
of a robust intelligence footprint there.
The war against terror was not successful the
way it was conducted. The war against terror was
counterproductive and in the end
led to more terror. In the end,
it helped the Taliban to return to power.
If ISIS-K continues to be an issue
and If the US continues to launch over the
horizon counterterrorism operations, we're
likely to see more collateral damage and we're
likely to see that collateral damage translate
into more support for jihadi groups.
Let's not view everything as just
a militaristic problem. Let's not combat
terror with weapons only. It needs a
different approach. It needs diplomacy.
It needs development. It needs dialogue.